hey this is presh talaker i received an
email that i wanted to share with you
wolfgang came up with a false proof that
two equals zero
when he showed it to his class no one
could figure out where the mistake was
not even his teacher
so i wanted to share a version of that
proof with you and ask can you figure
out where the mistake is
we start out with two equals one plus
one
one is also equal to the square root of
one
and one is also equal to negative one
times negative one
we now take the square root of each term
the square root of negative one is equal
to the imaginary number i
we have i times i which equals i squared
and i squared is equal to negative one
in the end we have one plus negative one
which equals zero
and all of this is equal to two
so we have proven that two is equal to
zero
clearly this is an absurd conclusion
so where is the mistake in this proof
give it a moment of thought before
watching the rest of the video where i
explain where the mistake comes from
so when wolfgang sent me this email i
immediately spotted the mistake because
it is a common fallacy
the problem comes when you take the
square root of a product of negative
terms
it's okay to take the square root of
negative one times negative one
what you cannot do is then take the
square root of each term
there is something called the product
rule of square roots
if you have the square root of 8 times b
that is equal to the square root of a
times the square root of b but it's
generally only true when both terms are
greater than or equal to zero
it doesn't work in this case when both
terms are negative one you can see
that's the mistake all of the other
steps in the proof are valid
so in math class you sometimes learn
these properties and they come with
these conditions like oh this is only
true both terms are greater than or
equal to zero you can see why these
terms absolutely matter you should
remember the conditions of these
properties because otherwise you can get
to absurd conclusions like in this case
two equals zero
so did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch one
of my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description